hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
early on in his confessions augustine
shares with us some very interesting
reflections
about his interest and love for
the theater and for
shows spectacular in latin
and
he's not unique in this by any means as
a matter of fact he points out the weird
dynamic that is involved already
in book one so that's where we should
look right off the bat this is in
chapter 10
and he talks about being interested in
other things like playing
and you know contests and false stories
and then he says that he had a curiosity
glittering more and more in his eyes for
shows for spectacular
and he calls these the games
in this case ludos which is accusative
right plural
ludus is the the singular for this ludi
is the famous games that were put on at
rome so the games the the
play things the
arrangements for
playing of older people myorum those who
are
adults those who are supposed to
you know
be more on the ball than the kids who
who presumably don't know what they're
doing
and he points out a certain
inconsistency here which is namely that
the kids if they engage in play which
could include watching shows or stuff
like that they get punished now why do
they get punished because they're not
developing their talents their
capacities through diligent study but
what are they supposed to be using those
talents that they're developing for
well to help put on shows or do other
similarly
silly things
he talks about
parents gladly letting their children be
beaten if by attending just such shows
they're kept from studies which their
parents wish them to rise to putting on
similar plays and he says lord in your
mercy look down on these things why is
he saying that because it's so screwed
up now it's interesting that he brings
up mercy
because that's going to play an
important role in book three where
there's a much longer discussion about
shows and this is when augustine is no
longer just a child but you know kind of
a young grown-up himself so this is in
chapter two which is rather longish
and there's a lot of stuff going on
there
that's rather
puzzling
to augustine but he also
gives us some
guidance about this as well so he says
that the theater
the spectacular teatrica right so the
the um shows the spectacles of the
theater
enraptured him and takes hold of him
literally
uh it shows we're filled with pictures
images literally of my own now he said
he's got a word here miseries miseria
right this is going to be used a lot in
this chapter
missouri means you know bad things
things that make you
miserable now
he's very quickly going to tell us that
no it's not just you know
a show about me and what's going on with
me he goes to the show to see other
people's
miseries as well including how they
sometimes
overcome them
and we we watch people in conflict
in
adversity in feeling bad for themselves
and we feel something good
as a
result
so why does he go there to see
depictions of other people's
miseries and we can say
why the hell would you do that doesn't
that just make you feel bad yourself
and the answer is
yeah i kind of like feeling bad in that
way
and if you think about some of our own
genres of
shows movies think about horror movies
we like to be scared right
if it's not a scary movie we're like
well that's not a very good horror movie
maybe grossed out right why do people
watch true crime stuff it could be fear
it could be like i want to see people
get revenge on each other it could be oh
you know i feel so bad for this family
and what they've gone through
but
it's not really that different than what
augustine is talking about happening
on stage think about greek tragedy even
think about comedy
comedy is quite often somebody's going
to be in the one down position
somebody's going to fall down the stairs
somebody's going to lose their fortune
and so he asks
why is it
that we like to
grieve to feel bad
over doleful and tragic events that we
wouldn't want to have happen
to ourselves you know why why do we go
and watch poor oedipus go through in his
his kids
who are also his brothers and sisters go
through all these problems well because
we get something
out of it and so there's going to be
this distinction that's made
between depicted and unreal miseries and
the the real miseries that we ourselves
encounter and experience and we feel
bad with both of them but we feel bad in
different ways
so
augustine goes on and he says the
spectator likes to experience
grief delor you know pain sadness at
these scenes and this sorrow
is actually
a
pleasure a voluptas
it's it's a mixed thing when we watch
horror movies
you know if if we were really in a
situation in which these terrible events
are happening
if we take pleasure in that that there's
something wrong with us right but we sit
there and we watch these movies and we
compare them to each other oh that one
gets three stars because you know not
really that believable uh this one's a
really great one scared the crap out of
me even on the 10th watching you know
this one's a classic freddy krueger how
can you go wrong with him right and and
we could go on and on and on this is not
something foreign to us
and he says this is a foolishness
the more a person is moved by these
things the less free they are from these
passions so it's not good for us right
and here's where the distinction comes
in
when we experience it we call it misery
miseria in latin when other people
experience it
and we're
experiencing it in a vicarious way with
them it's not actually happening to us
it's happening to somebody else and it's
happening kind of at a distance it's not
you know we're not
uh spectators on the scene of a terrible
crash in which we're seeing people with
you know blood and guts spilling out in
front of us
instead we're seeing it on the stage
that is something different we feel
what in latin is called
misericordia and there's a lot of ways
of translating this mercy is one of the
ways in which it's legitimately
translated we could also think of it as
pity or compassion right we feel for
somebody else because something bad
has happened to them and he says that we
actually
like this
he says what kind of mercy is it to be
shown to these unreal things on the
stage
here's where another vital difference
comes in
we don't help the people on the stage i
mean if we do then they
remove us from the theater right if you
see somebody getting bullied on the tv
and you're like you know picking up
things and throwing it at the oh stop
that that's bad people are like
this is a tv show buddy there's
something wrong with you same thing with
the theater
so
there's a distance there we're not to go
to the aid of the others we're only
asked to
feel something
and if we don't feel something then the
play
the theater right is unsuccessful and
well this is not a very good production
right i don't feel
anything
we like to feel something
for
these people that we're
not connected with and are only watching
so he says
tears and sorrows
therefore
are objects of love meaning we
desire we
love to feel tears and sorrow not to
feel tears and sorrow because we stubbed
our own toe or fell down the stairs or
lost a lot of money in the stock market
or you know alienated the love of our
life or
you know lost a child or something like
that we don't want to feel tears and
sorrow about that although perhaps some
people actually do
indulge themselves
in that way in taking pleasure in their
grief
but we do take
pleasure in somebody else's
grief
so he says
nobody wants to be wretched but we do
want to be
merciful we do want to have misericordia
since mercy cannot exist apart from
grief is it for this sole reason
that grief is
loved this is a possible explanation you
know um
those who were involved with we have to
extend misericordia that is compassion
or mercy towards them and so maybe we
can you know take some
love enjoyment whatever desire towards
that that grief because it allows us to
be merciful to others how does that
apply to people on the stage though
and he says
[Music]
should mercy be
cast aside
no
at certain times
sorrows may be loved
but
he says today i still feel compassion
i'm a grown-up man now but in those days
at the theater i felt joy together with
the lovers when by shameful means they
had joy in each other you know a lot of
the stories were like people getting it
on and tricking their spouses or you
know tricking their parents and being
able to express their love for for each
other right and so you go to the theater
and you're like oh man this is great
they're they're uh doing
good but they're not really doing good
they're they're doing something bad but
we're like this is this is awesome and
he says although these things were
pretended in the show when they lost
each other i became sad
like one who feels compassion is it
accordia both situations
gave me delight so that was old me that
was past me augustine is saying the me
who was addicted to you know theater
stuff or as we would say media right
and he says now
i've i've matured
i have more pity for one who rejoices in
a shameful deed than for one who has
suffered damage to a pernicious pleasure
lost some vile joy this is the truer
mercy and sorrow delore you know sadness
finds no delight
in it so you know now i i actually feel
misery compassion towards those who are
still screwing up and who have things
mixed up that could be towards fictional
characters but why not feel it towards
real people
instead and he said something really
interesting here
he says
if there is a good will that is at the
same time bad willed and he uses
uh
benevolentia and male valentia here
to talk about these these volitions
these wills these ways of comporting
ourselves is it possible
for us to be
both good willed and bad willed at the
same time
and he says um that's not really
possible that cannot be right it cannot
be thought
um
then only he says only a truly and
sincerely merciful person can wish there
would be some unfortunate so they could
show mercy
towards them and he says that's more
like the mercy that god is actually
showing to us you you love our souls or
the purity of love more deep and wide
than we have for ourselves and you're
unalterably merciful you don't suffer
any wound from sorrow so it's you notice
that there's a distinction here that's
that's being spelled out between
miseria
dolor
you know being miserable feeling sorrow
and
misericordia in the theater these are
all kind of mixed up together it's other
people's miseries they make me feel sad
then i get to feel compassion towards
these other people that's not the way
that that we want to be so going to the
theater is kind of messing us up
according to augustine right and we can
ask how should we feel
this visitor cordia this compassion in
good ways and he goes on and he says
my wretchedness
at the time
is that i loved to feel sorrow it's like
picking out a scab right or or hurting
yourself in some way and i sought out
opportunities for sorrow
in the false misery of another person
mimicked on the stage depicted on the
stage in my imagination
that actor's playing pleased me most and
had the strongest attraction which
struck
tears
from my eyes
what wonder was it that i
should be infected with these loathsome
sores and what does he mean by wilson
source dynamics that are
you know the product of screwed up
emotional management that gets worse and
worse inflamed by going to the
screwed up theater which could be used
for good but oftentimes isn't because we
don't really know what we're doing with
this and he says hence came my love for
such sorrows and there is a good part to
this
i was not pierced deep down i didn't
like to suffer such things and only to
look at them and by which when they were
heard and performed i was scratched
lightly as it were
the scratches made by fingernails
they're followed a burning tumor and
horrible horrid pus and wasting away you
know so he's saying you got to watch out
when it comes to the theater so as not
to get yourself all mixed up
emotionally and become worse off by
indulging yourself in this now here's
something i'd like to bring in
just as a quick ending
augustine could go to shows when they
put shows on
we live in a time of streaming media
where there is more than we could ever
possibly watch in our life at our
fingertips so perhaps we have to be more
on guard if augustine is right
about this interconnection between
miseries compassion
and
sadness brought about through media
you